[Musique]
vous êtes dans la forêt de montvert les
hauts donc sur la commune de saint
pierre pour vous présenter l'opération
de restauration écologique pilotes
manquent sur cet espace naturel sensible
des parties
[Musique]
c'est un projet qui s'inscrit dans le
programme de plantation d'un million
d'arbres du département
alors vous vous trouvez dans une forêt
qui a été acquise par le département 80
pour la protéger puisque à l'origine
cette forêt était menacé par un faux
projet de défrichement donc l'ensemble
de cette forêt devaient être rasées pour
mettre en place des prairies d'élevage
dont le département est intervenu pour
la préserver durablement
malheureusement dans cette forêt
primaire qui est inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco vous avez une
enclave d'anciennes friches de prairies
dans laquelle on se trouve actuellement
dans laquelle vous avez des espèces
exotiques envahissantes qui petit à
petit vont proliférer se développer
envahir la forêt environnante et risque
de la détruire
donc on intervient sur cette friche qui
fait environ 6 hectares pour cicatriser
en fait le milieu c'est à dire qu'on va
reboiser cette prairie avec des espèces
indigènes pour refermer le milieu pour
refaire une peau si on veut et permettre
à la forêt de s'installer et à terme on
aura donc reconstituer la la continuité
écologique de tout le massif qui s'étend
depuis la plaine des grègues jusqu'à
notre dame de la paix sur 800 hectares
[Musique]
alors pour ce projet qui fait 6 hectares
là nous en sommes phase des essais
préliminaires les essais de mécanisation
et plantations pourquoi c'est parce
qu'il ya des incertitudes par rapport au
sol par rapport au climat par rapport
aux espèces qu'ils vont tenir ou pas
tenir donc avec l'équipe de spl on fait
des essais de plantation en ligne à la
mécanisation après girobroyage et on va
encore faire des essais de plantation en
ligne avec un pic à cannes c'est à dire
qu'on va faire un sillon et on va
planter dans le sillon pourquoi parce
que lorsqu on plante un arbre qui coûte
10 euros faut dépenser 40 euros à 50
euros pour en assurer l'entretien
sinon les espèces invasives on se
développe et puis finalement vont finir
par étouffer l'arbre et le tuer mais cet
entretien coûte très cher donc laissé il
consiste à notamment à faire des essais
de mécanisation pour limiter les coûts
[Musique]